the u.s has officially dropped coveted
testing requirements for international
travelers the announcement was made
friday by the biden administration and
today is the first day that new
guideline has been enacted madison
kimbrough caught up with some
international travelers this evening she
joins us live at harry reid
international with more madison
today is a big day for international
travelers and while many are thrilled
that the covet testing has been lifted
many say this doesn't change the fact
that the virus is still out there
it just feels like a kind of a weight's
kind of lifted
there's a lot of that testing the day
before your flight is pretty stressful
requirements for international travelers
entering the u.s have eased up this week
the biden administration announced that
on sunday the covet 19 testing
requirement for people traveling abroad
would be lifted ending one of the
longest running travel restrictions of
the pandemic londoner leticia kayatoo
says even with the announcement she
still wanted to test beforehand but
feels like the u.s is headed in the
right direction with this decision i
still did it just in case because you
never know i think it's going to be much
better you know in terms of organization
you know stress international travelers
were required to show proof of a
negative test a day before flying into
the u.s something that the travel
industry had repeatedly urged the
administration to draw however with the
recent surge in covet cases here in
southern nevada some travelers say they
will still take precaution for our peace
of mind we will continue to wear our
masks as far as travel goes i know a lot
of people were happy not having to
to do the attestation and all that stuff
so
it makes it easier to travel and the cdc
making it clear that they will reassess
this decision in 90 days to see if there
is a need to reinstate a pre-departure
testing requirement
tonight four international flights are
set to land two from london and two from
canada reporting live in harry reid
international airport madison kimbrough
live local now